hey come on net come get a sneak peek of
the family fuego house created by
directv
so this is our living room this is where
we spend a lot of our time we have jesus
young over here
leo gonzalez monica villa and isabella
ferregood and this is where a lot of our
creative juices flow we have a lot of
conversations and where a lot of our
magic happens
all right and this is our studio and
some of our most famous content like
fuego shore is filmed right here hey
guys at 23 years old alexia's got 1.5
million followers we teamed up with her
and directv for this tour of the first
ever latinx tic-tac house familia fuego
a place created to serve as a launch pad
for diverse talent i always say
representation is so important
especially for people to be able to see
themselves through us so we want to
inspire we want to elevate the
communities that we come from and this
is all being made possible thanks to
directv that is providing us with
everything that we could possibly need
yes another content house so this house
is a creative hub where we're literally
doing what we love every day making
people laugh
we have a great bond like we're super
close we really are like a family
all right it's time for you guys to get
going we have a lot of work to do be
sure to follow familia fuego on all
socials and head to directv.com fuego to
learn more